He wants the personification of the evil dictator clad in his familiar khaki
uniform men's cap and chomping on a cigar.
He ruled with an iron fist over his island nation.
He took on the United States and brought the world to the brink of nuclear
holocaust,
shifting his attention to his own country.
He decimated the economy,
creating a communistic dictatorship that forced the people to revere him even as
he ruined their lives.
In this episode of Biographics,
we take a closer look at the life of Fidel Castro.
Del Castro was born on August the 13th 1926 and the small farming village of
monogamous in northern rnt and Cuba.
His father and Heller caster you Gus had emigrated from Spain in 1898 and picks
up work as a brick layer and the railroad worker before starting his own
business selling lemonade to field workers.
From this humble start,
he built a small sugarcane embark and praising 26,000 acres and 300 work
families.
And how's the first wife Maria go?
I gave birth to two children and then either died or simply walked out on the
family.
Unhealth soon.
Took up with his young,
made leaner Roos Gonzalez who bore him.
Three children and Yella of Amman and Fidel.
The couple were married shortly after Fidel is birth.
They were a relatively wealthy family who lived in a deletion style two story
house in the country still.
They did live a decidedly country lifestyle with chickens and pigs wandering
through the house.
Fidel was named after a local politician with his name,
meaning faithful.
He did have his father's temperaments,
which meant he was prone to violence outbursts.
His sister recalls that if he was playing baseball and just team we're losing.
He would simply gather up the equipments and walk off the fields.
Close friends and future novelist Gabriel Garcia Marquez recalled that Fidel was
the worst loser that did have a mask when he reached school age.
Fidel was sent to study and Santiago,
the second largest city in Cuba for the first two years.
He stayed with his godparents and was homeschooled by them.
After that,
he was enrolled at the Maris Lasalle school along with brothers Ramond and Raul.
Fidel soon gained a reputation as a troublemaker.
I was a bit of a bullied when he was in the fourth grade.
Fidel's father received a letter stating that his three boys with the biggest
bullies in the entire school and how was furious and pulled the boys out of the
school.
This enraged with Al who threatened to burn the house down.
He ended up being sent to a more demanding Jesuit school in Havana with his
father threatening to cut off his allowance if his grades dropped below a
certain level.
Fidel responses to this by forging his school reports.
Carsguru proved to be a decidedly average students,
but there was one area in which he excelled.
He had a photographic memory of facts,
which hugely impressed his fellow students.
They would call them,
do a page number from their tax books,
and he would recite the page word for word in his team's.
Fidel began to develop his ability as a public speaker and there's a debater.
After an initial rejection,
he gained acceptance into the Allover Bernardo Literary Academy,
which was the literary wing at the Jesuit School.
At first he was paralyzed by stage fright,
but he gradually became more relaxed and more confidence in his presentations
and obviously a very of 1945 Fidel entered law school at the University of
Havana.
At the time,
the university was a self governing body which for bead the police or army from
setting foot on campus.
As a result,
it was a hotbed of clandestine activity by gangsters and political agitators.
It was a very attractive environment for the hot headed Castro.
Fidelis first foray,
NC political imagination was precipitated by a rise in bus fares that had been
authorized by Cuban precedents ram on growl.
Castro organized a protest against the fair raisins,
led a march to the presidential palace.
The police beat the students with Fidel himself receiving slight injuries.
He used this incident to his advantage by going to the press and receiving some
sympathetic coverage.
At the time the Castro in roles at the university,
there were two main gangster groups who were vying for control,
the socialist revolutionary movements,
Msr,
and as the insurrection or revolutionary union you,
Iowa,
there were frequent violent clashes between these two groups.
Fidel quickly sized up the situation and began to maneuver between the two
groups.
In December of 1946 there was an assassination attempt on a leading member of
the Uir and Castro was fingered as the trigger man.
His that seem to motive here was that he wants it to ingratiate himself with the
MSR leadership.
As it turns out,
it was the leader of Ui,
Emilio Troy,
who took Castro under his wing.
He gave Fidel the pistol,
which the young budding revolutionary carries with them at all times throwing.
They'd been planning and invasion of the Dominican Republic in conjunction with
a group of Dominican exiles in response to the terrible conditions brought about
by the rule of Rafael Trujillo.
Task very quickly jumps on board and sales without 12,000 fellow revolutionaries
to Kayak on fetus on July the 29th 1947 for two months they arms.
When's paramilitary training before setting off for the Dominican mainlands.
Meanwhile,
three Ho had learned of the plans attack and didn't even appeal to the United
States.
For Eight,
the revolutionary leaders got cold feet and cools off the invasion.
Ams,
the embarrassed given army began rounding up the ships and taking the would be
attack is into custody.
Castrate managed to evade custody by jumping ship and swimming eight miles to
the shore.
In 1947 Castro visitors a new model prison on the isle of Pines as part of his
legal studies,
my name or sons,
Havana,
he criticized the prison and it's inhumane treatment of its inhabitants.
The following year,
he was part of a student congress that traveled to Bogota,
Colombia.
On April the seventh the group maps with the leader of the Liberal Party,
Jorge Gasten,
who looked likely to win the upcoming election.
Two days later though,
Gaten was shot debt.
Bogota erupted in violence and the students from Cuba,
we're caught in the middle of it.
Castro became actively involved participating in the takeover of a police
station.
After three days,
the authorities restored order,
but not before some 3,500 people had been killed.
Gastro returns in Havana where he became a follower of Senator Eddie.
He bus the main opponents of president ground.
He was the founder of the Cubans.
People party.
Castro campaigned hard for hibiscus and is unsuccessful bid for the presidency
in 1948 I'm still the two men whenever close.
Keep us all.
Fidel as somewhat of an embarrassment user has gangsta backgrounds and Fidel
only ever viewed the leader as an obstacle to his own path to power.
In order to gain political respectability,
Castro cut off his association with his gangster associates.
He gave speeches on campus denouncing the two main gangs and naming names of
those who were responsible for criminal activity.
This made him a target for both groups and he was forced into hiding around this
time.
Fidel,
who was generally awkward and shy around women,
and that's martyr Diaz Balart,
the daughter of one of the wealthiest man in Cuba.
The couple of fell in love and were married in 1948 with motors father getting
them $10,000 for a three month honeymoon in the United States.
Most of their time was spent in New York where Fidel learn some English.
We're starting to Cuba.
The newlyweds moved into a hotel across the street from a military camp in
Havana.
In September of 1949 matter gave birth to a son who would become known as Fidel
Ito.
Having graduated from University of Fidel,
began a small law practice,
most of his title.
However,
we spent dabbling in politics on August the 15th 1951 people's party leader at
he hit us,
was giving his usual Sunday radio address,
urging the people to stop accepting the corruption of the government and take
action.
Even pulled out a pistol and shot himself in the stomach.
The dramatic act was intended to rouse the people keep us had spoken for too
long and to suicide attempt.
It's not broadcast for the next 11 days.
Keep us lay in a hospital bed in terrible agony.
Oh,
his side.
The entire time was Fidel Castro.
When the leader died,
Castro was prominence as part of the honor guard that stood outside the
university hall of Honor Work.
Give us in state how's the military escorts prepared to lead the body through
the streets in a large procession,
Castro and treated the captain to divert the root to the presidential palace.
Fidel was convinced that he could rouse the people to overthrow the government,
but the army captain refused fairing.
There's an absolute bloodbath.
We didn't see him the following year.
Castro ran for a seat on the Chamber of Deputies.
He managed to garner the support of the majority of the People's Party members
and looked in line to when the upcoming election.
However,
on March the 10th former presidents for NCO Battista stage a military coup and
seized.
However,
he began rounding up his political adversaries,
including members of the People's Party.
Fidel and his brother Raul went into hiding the buddies to queue diverted Castro
from what could have been the promising diplomatic Korea in favor of becoming a
fully fledged revolutionary.
You gathered together his own political group,
drawn from former party members and followers from his university days traveling
up and down the country,
put his oratorical lands,
propaganda skills to full of facts off to 14 months.
He had a following of 12,000 people.
He ran his organization with military precision and discipline.
Drinking alcohol was forbidden and t imposed strict sexual standards.
He also organized his forces at a cellular level.
We have members of each cell being unaware of the existence of other cells.
By the middle of 1953 Castro had the support base that he needed to stage his
own COO,
but he didn't have,
there were weapons or indeed the money to buy them.
His solution was to attack a military base and sees its weapons.
The base selectors was located at Mancado.
The attack,
however,
and was bungled from the start.
One of the 26 vehicles on route to the base had a flat tire and other took a
wrong turn and did not arrive until the attack was well underway.
When the remainder of the vehicles arrive to the base,
they were surprised to find it heavily fortified the military defenders,
so beach back the invaders with eight of Castro's men being killed,
the remains or floods,
but over the next few days,
many of them were rounded up by the authorities.
69 of them are eventually tortured and put to death.
Castro himself was put on trial before a military tribunal.
He used the opportunity to speak out about the regime of Patista as the harsh
treatments of his fellow revolutionaries.
His courtroom defense statements of history will absolve me,
which become probably his most famous speech still.
He was convicted and sentenced to 15 years and imprisonments Castro and his
followers were sent to the previous dimensions.
Isle of Pines Prison for doubt.
Muse does time that as who instilled a supreme level of order and discipline and
as men,
the Castro rebels gains a reputation for their good behavior and were given
great freedom.
Then on march the sixth 1954 Boeing's public pressure President Battista
grounded amnesty to Castro and dismantle the show of good faith from the
president's.
However,
did not stop Castro from speaking out about the regime.
When two of his men were beaten by Battista enforces Fidel became increasingly
concerned for his own safety.
He would move houses every two to three days and then just two months after
being released from prison,
he left Cuba from Mexico.
It was Casper.
Plan to build up and train a new wing of his revolutionary army in Mexico and to
then return to join forces with those already in Havana and a huge push to oust
the Patista regime is Mexican army began as a group of about 60 cube and the
factors who lived in six small houses under strict disciplinary conditions
imposed by Fidel.
It was during this period that castering that Ernesto Che Guevara,
who would play a key role in the coming revolution.
Castro launched his revolution in late November,
1956 from the port of Tox Pan on the Mexican coast.
It was planned to coincide with another uprising organized by a rival antibodies
to group for Dell had bought a 60 foot boat that was designed to take a maximum
of 25 passengers and deepen the old 82 of his men on board as it shoved its way
towards Cuba.
The boat was in constant danger of capsizing.
The journey was so slow that the five day trip took seven days,
meaning that they would miss the uprising of the other group with the boats
beach at a place called purgatory points.
On December the second,
but by now,
but he's designy who had already put down the fast rebellion had landed that
Castro was on his way and his,
that he had planes overhead ready to strafe the invaders and bomb the area.
Only about a dozen men survived Castro and Guevara or among them they again a
three day march through the forest,
constantly being hounded from the ad by the Cuban air force.
They finally reached the Sierra Maestra region where they settled with the local
villages and began to regroup.
Six weeks later,
Castro led 33 men on a gorilla raid on a tiny army garrison in La Plata.
Two soldiers were killed and the rebels stole off with a number of weapons.
A month after this attack,
gastric decided it was time to get its propaganda machine in motion.
He sent one of his men to Havana to bring a foreign journalist back to the camp.
The man chosen was from the New York Times and Suny three part story had
appeared in the paper describing the massive military buildup.
Castro was organizing in the south of Cuba,
Castro support based group exponentially with more and more disaffected Cubans
joining his rags.
In March of 1958 younger brother Raul began to establish the second force out of
Oriente,
which soon grew in number.
Raul proved to be a highly capable military commander with his force capturing
and destroying many planes,
tanks and military vehicles.
In April for the cold calls upon the people of Cuba to stage and nationwide
strike,
he believed that this would be the start of his long plans uprising.
President Battista responded by threatening to shoot anyone who participated in
the strike.
As a result,
more than 140 people were shot down in the street,
but this action only fueled Castro support base and it's even more people stream
to support him with the tight now decidedly turned in his favor.
Castro decided to move.
He sent Che Guevara and another of his commanders,
Camilo [inaudible] goes on a Westwood march towards Savannah.
Along with their rebel forces.
The government forces put up virtually no resistance and the rebels were able to
take control.
One town after another on December the 31st 1958 with Castro's men closing in,
but he start resigned and fled the country.
Three days later,
Castro arrived in Santiago to a hero's welcome.
He gave a speech in front of 200,000 people.
I was later Guevara or NCN for he goes,
marched into Havana and seized control of the reins of power and just like that,
the Castro era had begun yet
transfer of power with amazingly orderly Castro would want his mat and against
fluting or destroying property.
He had come to power on the backs of an army of poor and illiterate peasants.
Now that he had gained power,
he would need to educate men to help him govern.
He tries to a point,
his former professor,
Jose Miro Cardona as prime minister,
Renzi Manwell Aricia to be president.
He made himself supreme commander of the armed forces behind the scenes.
However,
gastro put the organization in place to ensure that he was the holder of overall
power in the weeks following the revolution.
More than 500 Patista officials were tried,
convicted,
and put to death.
That number would rise to 1,900 over the coming year.
Within seven months of seizing power,
Castro decided that he no longer had any need for a public governments.
On July the 16th,
he announced that he was resigning his position as on Monza because he could no
longer work with precedent.
[inaudible]
he had accused him of corruption.
Castro then disappeared for a number of days.
Justice Fidel had intended the people who rose up in protest and demanded that
the president must go the fries and the president sought sanctuary in the
Venezuelan embassy before escaping the country.
This allowed Castro to resent it in triumph and to point himself as President
Castro.
Now in post totalitarian rule,
those who did not give him that absolute support.
We're in danger of being seized and put on trial or just simply shot.
Within a few short months,
all signs of resistance within Cuba,
including critical media,
had simply been removed.
Now,
Castro fixed his attention on securing external security.
Uh,
focus was perched on increasing the size and the strength of his army.
Six months soft up seizing power,
Castro and visited the United States where he was greeted with enthusiasm by the
media as well as politicians and the public behind the scenes.
However,
the Eisenhower governments was already making plans for Castro's removal
in February of 1960 the Cuban leader signs and agreements with the Russians by
which Cuban sugar would be traded for military arms and oil.
This was at the height of the Cold War and many of the oil refineries in Cuba
where American owns when the owners refuse to process Soviet oil imports,
Castro sees their businesses.
The U s government responded by cutting 700,000 tons from the U S and your
purchase commitments intern at Castro nationalized Usi and its agriculture and
industrial businesses.
Castro has move,
had a huge impact on the u s mafia,
which would cost about a hundred million dollars worth of property in the
tourist industry alone.
During this period of nationalization,
more than 200 thousands professional and upper costs,
citizens fled the country.
Relations between the United States and Cuban government's became so strange
that in March of 1960 President Eisenhower greenlit the training of a group of
Cuban exiles to stage an invasion and seek control.
The bowl was picked up by President Kennedy resulting in the disastrous Bay of
Pigs invasion,
gastric gusts of winds of the invasion,
and how does forces ready and waiting with their lack of promised USS support.
The Cuban rebels cut to pieces on December the first 1961 Castro when's on
national television and Declan's that he was a Marxist Leninist and would be
until the day he died.
The Soviets took eight where he view of their newly declared communist fellow
that the Americans responded immediately imposing a total economic blockade from
Cuba.
This led to economic disaster with massive food shortages resulting.
Finally,
the Soviet government decided to embrace Castro.
They offered to station Soviet missiles on the islands.
In Middle October,
1962 the American government's got concrete evidence of the missile operation
leading to what became known as the Cuban missile crisis.
Resident Kennedy placed a total military blockade around Cuba and announced that
a military attack from Cuba on any nation would be seen as a direct attack by
the Soviet Union on the United States.
Castro urged the Russians to make a preemptive strike on the United States if
the Americans attacks the islands after 13 days during which the world was a
hair trigger away from nuclear destruction,
the Russians backed down and agreed to remove the missiles.
Castro was left completely out of the negotiation process and he was not happy.
Soviet president's,
Nikita Khrushchev tries to placate him by inviting Castro on a 40 day trip
through the Soviet Union.
During the trip,
Khrushchev offered to provide economic aid to the struggling islands.
In 1965 the United States announced that it was willing to take in Cuban
refugees.
This led to a mass exodus with a result in huge loss of skills and manpower on
the island
with international situation and having settled Castro satisfied [inaudible] on
making agricultural reforms to improve the economy.
He wants to increase the sugar harvest and set a target for national production.
In 1965 5.5 million tons increasing to 10 million tons by 1970 these
expectations,
however,
they were totally unreasonable still,
he paused nearly all of the country's economic resources into the sugar cane
industry,
leaving all other economic activity.
Baron,
the whole country,
including the elderly,
young children and military workers were put to work in the fields in a
desperate quest to reach his targets.
Even Castro himself,
we sent two of cut cane for four hours every day.
How's the rest of the Cuban economy?
It fell by 20 and 40% the sugar cane project failed dismally to reach its
projected targets.
In 1970 Castro announced that the plant had failed typical of his flat for the
dramatic.
He resigned his presidency.
The people demanded that he returned and soon he was back in power and the sugar
crisis was behind him.
Throughout the 1970s Castro began looking for ways to extend his influence
abroad.
He began involving himself in revolutionary movements and sending forces to
train and lead various guerrilla operations.
It's supportive.
Civil wars in Angola and Somalia ate up more of his countries with limited
resources.
During the early 1980s sugar prices and production has increased significantly.
This allowed the Cuban economy to grow at a rate of 24% but when the sugar price
slumped dramatically,
Cuba's international debt ballooned to $6 billion.
At the same time,
it's still owed $19 billion to the Soviet Union.
The Soviets trying to help by increasing trade with the fall of the Soviet
Union.
In 1989 all the agreements fell apart.
The already week you've been economy was severely restricted.
Strict to rationing was put in place.
The electricity supply became sporadic and tractors were replaced with ox drawn
carts where there's country on the brink of collapse.
In 1993 Castro Cubans to start private businesses.
The following year,
he permitted foreign investors to own given businesses as well.
If the economy which had declined by 40% in the past three years,
finally began to grow.
By the 1990s castrate was an aging isolators and largely depressed dictator.
The majority of his close associates were either dead or had been exiled.
He still keeps up his habit of staying in one place for any two or three nights,
so he was constantly being moved around and a bulletproof Mercedes limousine
during this period of Castro's tight grip on the country seems to loosen
slightly,
but then in March of 2003 he imposed a crackdown,
which Sol scores of journalists,
students,
and professional people arrested us dissidents of the regime.
In July of 2006 the 80 year old Castro underwent surgery for internal bleeding.
The following year he handed over the presidential rents to his brother Raul.
From then Fidelis health grants relate to Terrie right it.
The ends finally came on November the 26th of 2016 though the exact cause of his
death was never released.
The country was in mourning for nine days.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the rice and other ways.
Thank you for watching.